[Music]
I already do anime crew it is I Griffin
the vo guy L the wizard the video editor
Dom hopefully she could not be here but
that's okay all right weep Squad don't
tell the boys but the real reason I did
not go to Anime Expo is because I wanted
to use that 500 that I would have spent
on an anime figurine on a watch look at
this bad boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyways we've been given a mission by
Dom to buy well technically waste but no
buy one thousand dollars worth of anime
figurines and he's going to decide who
makes the best one let's go now before I
show you how I spent my money on super
super duper important anime figurines
why the heck did nobody tell me that I
had a plastic tag under my right ear the
entire time that we recorded this video
why so the boys have to walk up to any
random cosplayer or anime guy and have
them pick up an anime figurine which
will be later judged by Dom AKA The weeb
King he's not not really a king they
don't realize that everything here is
overpriced as hell
so Tundra from Demon Slayer figuring
Demon Slayer yep 100
35 dollars
35 dollars
it's insane all right cool thank you no
problem thank you little did I know just
how cheap that actually was so Griffin
just bought his first 35 bucks
uh right
it seems that we're gonna have a lot of
figurines and I don't know how I'm gonna
bring it home
oh
which one personally I think that looks
amazing yep
you know I don't know what you like
actually you know I do like let's see
Dragon Ball Z One Piece JoJo that's all
great Attack on Titan is awesome
thank you
Kaizen I like that too
would it be risky if I actually choose
something that doesn't have a price tag
right now I would say if I say the JoJo
right there
oh all right Perfect Look at that I'm
gonna do it
and our Rider dumb he was like hey
here's a great idea why don't you guys
buy anime figurines we're like okay yeah
and buy a lot of them I'm like oh this
reenactment is 100 accurate how am I
going to waste my money today
oh let's see
I want something big like something just
like just like takes effort
you know yeah taking effort on my wallet
so should I do Yamcha
I have Rose black Goku over there
I have old school Vegeta powering up in
the manga Dimension so it looks like
he's coming right on the anime okay or
you go with gear four Loop if you forgot
leg day
and we have all the wipers down there
the ones that can go faster
out of my way over here thank you so
much
you have left from your about 350 bucks
is what I got left right
[Laughter]
because
it's pretty good like especially if
you're looking like I don't know if
you've seen them out of box we have them
over on the other side they're huge and
they're heavily detailed so they're like
hey you're listening you're like the
weeb sage I'm like the weave
intermediate and Dom is our weave King
let's see
all right you know what I'm going to get
to bring Goku premium well you know if
you're getting the premium for rainbow
you gotta get the matching one so you
have a full set because they're almost
oh
that would be genius because if you look
on the side of the package
let's see it shows
that's true you're right
I think she wants me to be broke yes I
think she really was I do appreciate
that honesty is a great thing
all right I'm gonna do it it's honestly
terrifying how quickly you can spend
money here
you know what I'm gonna go for dinky and
I'm hopefully that will nudge me over to
the finish line and to Victory there you
go that is a couple of dinky ones you
know
I got a couple of big impressed raw you
know big so strong right hooks I'm
hoping a few Jabs will secure me the
victory my time at the Anime Expo was
overwhelmingly exhaustingly fun there
was so much to do so much to see there
was so many people it was insane you
think every day there'd be less and less
people oh no no no no no each day there
was more and more people at the Anime
Expo it was crazy but I was able to
interact with people I never met with my
entire life before and act like as if I
knew them my entire life which was so
cool all because of anime and I kind of
did feel desperate that I must win the
anime figurine contest so I did
overspend a little bit hopefully Tom
won't hold it against me in our contest
which if he knows what's good for him
will pick me as the winner all right
what did you anime crew as Dom would say
I might have oversped just a little bit
but I had a gift card so it brought me
within my budget because I'm smart
so I'm hopefully I'm hoping this love is
gonna allow me to win I'm hoping let's
find out what the heck is copium all
right that's now it's my turn it's
Albert your editor I have 500 bucks I've
been watching Griffin film this and now
I know his tricks his chips
his tricks he only bought four so I'm
gonna win that fight quality I'm gonna
be win by quantity
oh in front of the store
in front of the location there is a
mystery gift bag for 50 bucks and we
don't know what's inside and we're gonna
do that one because you know what I love
gacha mechanics it's gonna be good
so yeah we're doing this one
uh yeah it's 50 bucks is it cash only
you think
the box and then you also will get
guaranteed a shirt as well yeah
[Music]
thank you all right sounds good have a
good one
all right let's go we got this one that
was a waste of 50 bucks but anyway anime
Expos where all anime lovers and even
manga lovers converge look at these
cosplayers Ichigo Genji impact Tokyo
Revengers your your your
yours are so many yours but because
there's a wide selection of people
around hopefully they're not gonna give
me the Normie stuff right hey can I have
to can I ask you a question so yeah
we're filming a video that we have to
spend 500 bucks for figurines for a
challenge and I'm facing him and I just
I just bought a 50
mystery bag that I don't know if I'm
gonna win with this do you have any
suggestions to buy this one and I'll
pick whatever you pick it was awesome
though
uh
see the Dilemma I've been having for 30
minutes because I want to win
zero double zero that one yeah
all right let's get zero yeah it's like
that channel how to beat anime
yeah look it up all right thanks man
last one
all right it's 150 down gonna look for a
different store
something fun
the first one is Zorro he's cool he's
pretty alright hopefully the next one's
gonna be better next one's gonna be less
Normie alright let's go so you can pick
what over there whatever over there
if you want a recommendation I have that
Hawks one the one Russian plastic it is
gorgeous the way they did the wings oh
is that the one you want me to buy
it's your pick
yes yes that one okay okay let's do it
the Hawks one one piece right no no no
no actually I got that all wrong my hero
Academia yeah
the Hawks one the plastic one
oh yeah
I just spent 180.
thank you so much
holy [ __ ] 180 dollars for my hero
Academia and it's not even the main
character
what's your favorite anime Fruits Basket
fruit backers of course
hold on a second did you say my friends
my roommates are favoring this fruit
baskets
Miku one up there Miku yeah that one
okay
I guess we're doing that one this one
all right how do we grab this do we have
anyone
all right are we excited for the
comeback yes they come back that's why
that's why and they said they're gonna
come up with like the more of the
stories that we're missing from the
manga
so do Society
can go 160 150 that's fine but
don't go 200.
break him that would be great
the Vegeta ran
all right is that one pick for you guys
Vegeta run we have 90 uh but we have a
hundred dollars left okay all in favor
so 90. you have 50 left okay question
how much for uh zero two
dude
[Applause]
all right
all right sounds good man yeah
hey just shout out to UV cropworks he
made this awesome sphere I got a cage
you make some amazing work of our works
of art he does an amazing job and he's
very fast
I want to give a shout out to uh Yakuza
uh AKA Chi for helping me make this uh
bleach sword for Ichigo
I think this is definitely a grand
celebration of a return of a very very
fun and popular Pond you know what he's
right anime experts but getting back
together with all your friends from all
across the world it's not about buying a
lot of anime figurines it's about
getting together with a community that
we have built so far I'm not even mad
that I just bought another one piece
character and Vegeta that's
great but you can watch our podcast next
week where Don will pick who has the
best anime figurine collection from
Anime Expo so see you next week bye